all right i said we will go on to shape
don't write the word shape there's a
different word that starts with s that
we use to describe the shape of a
distribution of data uh it has to do
with which way the data leans does
anyone know the word say it again ladder
skew okay so if you can write down the
word sku for me or sometimes in
textbooks um and out in the statistical
world they'll sometimes call this
skewness
uh but it's the same deal okay
now much like with modality there's
roughly speaking three kinds of skewness
that we're interested in
one two
three
we'll have a look at the middle one
first because it's actually the one that
you tend to see a lot or associate with
data i even drew one on the board okay
skews about which way a data set leans
so it's actually also to do with
symmetry
or lack of symmetry as we're about to
have a look at right so being that it's
about symmetry if you have a data set
like this unimodal one that i drew
before that's like oh it looks pretty
balanced between the left and the right
yeah it doesn't have any skewness to it
it's symmetrical so this is whoa
i'm doing terribly here this is the
first kind of skewness that we're
interested in when you don't have any
skewness at all okay
now then if you i know let's draw one
here so this is right in the middle okay
you then have two other kinds of
skewness that we're interested in
and you have to be really careful on how
you draw them i'm going to draw one like
this so there's a hump here and then
there's a long tail going that way and
then i've got another one here where
there's a hump here and a long tail
going that way okay now this is
counterintuitive lots of people get
fooled by this but we'll do our best
okay one of these is positive skew and
the other one is
negative skew
which one is which does anyone know
which one is which yeah go ahead um
this is negative skew well done you can
all jot it down with me this is negative
screw this is the reason why by the way
i gave it to you in this order negative
skew no skew and then we call this one
positive skew
now the reason why i kind of flagged is
a bit weird right is because most people
would say hey hey when you have a look
here
the thing that dominates this data like
you can see the mode right there right
it looks like it's on the positive side
in that direction to the right so why do
we call it negative skew right there's
two ways at least that you can think
about this that i'll try and highlight
okay the way that i got taught which was
completely dissatisfying to me but it
worked is you have a look at
where the tail is let's have a look at
where the tail is be interested in the
tail rather than in the mode so this is
one way to say look that tail is facing
in the negative direction so this is
negatively skewed okay that's one way to
think about it
this is actually the technical
definition can you go ahead on all three
of these can you mark in the mode for me
so
this would be the mode this would be the
mode
this would be the mode okay
you remember we talked before about the
fact that you've got different kinds of
measures of central tendency we've got
mode
we've got median and then there's the
one that we looked at this morning we
calculated which was mean right now i
want you to have a think about each of
these right all three of them in fact
where would the mean
the average be
in relation to each of these three data
sets
we'll do the easiest one first
when you've got a symmetrical data set
the mode
and the mean
they're roughly equal right so i'm going
to put x
bar
i will never forget my pencil case again
because i'm so irritated um x bar i'm
gonna put right there on top of the mode
okay
when you have a look at this negative
skew over here right you've got a big
peak in here but actually sorry i take
about let's i'll give you a better
example this one you got a big peak here
down the bottom but then you've got this
trailing tail up as you go in the
positive direction now my favorite
example of this
is world income in fact let's just write
that
for example world income
why is it that world income looks like
this it's positively skewed
hmm
how would you say
josh uh because like all the retro
yeah very good so um if you have a think
about up here right uh you've got uh
you've got all the
the millionaires and billionaires and so
on right um you might call them
oligarchs depending on what country they
live in there's not that many of them in
the world scheme okay but they hold a
huge amount of wealth so by definition
there can't be too many of them okay
but think about the impact that they
have on the mean
think about the impact they have on the
mean let's suppose there's us here in
the room there's 20 of us
and let's just say our income is i don't
know not a bad graduate salary that's
called a hundred thousand dollars
okay so at the moment
the mean and the mode are both a hundred
thousand dollars make sense
okay let's put
let's put jeff bezos in the room
a single outlier someone on this
trailing tail does anyone know what jeff
bezos is worth
i actually don't know the answer
okay so depending on how you calculate
his net worth right but let's just pluck
a number out of the air i'm pretty sure
he's not just a millionaire i'm pretty
sure he's like in the order of like
hundreds of millions okay
now this is not a rhetorical question
what's the mean now
can you get your calculator out and tell
me i know roughly where it is but i'm
actually interested in a number now
right we knew without jeff in the room
we knew what the mean was with precision
now there's 21 of us in the room
including this guy who earns 100 million
dollars so can you give me now
a figure for what the x-bar is when you
include
our amazon owner what do you got your
number for me
yeah josh go ahead oh no i'm hot i'm
understanding that your face is
networked 171 billion okay i was like
so in the shall i put some more zeros
here i think we'll get the point even if
we do 100 million okay you've got number
yeah
i'm just gonna buy 47 million is that
okay yeah okay 47 million
one outlier
right so this is happening from the skew
in this data there only has to be one
person up there so long as they're this
far off and apparently i was 1 000 times
less than 1 000 times off the amount of
money 47 million is nowhere close to any
of us right does that make sense so
where is and um again if you've got
different color you can see where i put
this in a dashed line right where is the
mean going to be it's going to skew
which way
positively that makes sense this is the
actual definition when we talk about
skewness it's about where is the mean in
relation to the mode can i say that one
more time because so important and this
will help you understand why it's
negative why it's positive
this word here or this word here is
tell me where the mean is
in relation to the mode
where is the mean
in relation
to the mode right you've got most your
people here but your mean is going to
get pulled away based on where the tail
goes and that's why that was kind of a
shorthand that my teachers taught me
just look at where the tail is that's
the way it's going right but i never
knew why the tail mattered it's because
the tail does this
jeff bezos is the tail does this make
sense i hope it actually sticks in your
mind meaningfully now rather than just
being like a i don't know why that
matters okay
all right so let me pause it does anyone
have any questions oh actually i have a
question of you guys i gave you a
positive skew example can you give me a
negative skew example
where is it that we've got like most of
the people up here and not that many
people down here
okay if you've got lots of jeff bezos is
fine okay um can you give me an actual
example from like real life i'm thinking
of one right now because we live in
australia yeah
population density what do you mean by
that
mhm
right
population
density so these are trickier because in
terms of population density like a
question which i would pose to all of
you is what would the horizontal axis be
right we could have a we know the
vertical axis would be density right but
it's like oh how do i meaningfully
measure this maybe you would do it as
like distance from the coast or
something like that right that might be
a way to do it because in australia that
would matter i have one that's related
to this with people you can see often
when we look at people we get
interesting patterns like this
i would think of one like and this is
worth writing by the way because again
like i said the examples are something
you have to learn not just what they
mean but where are they right i would
say that mortality
in developed countries would be
negatively skewed
let me say that again mortality in
developed countries what does mortality
mean
sickness but more specifically it's like
when do people die at what age do they
die right
yeah yeah morbidity right um
co-morbidities and all that so in a
developed country like australia right
we actually have an aging population we
have good enough healthcare good enough
nutrition and all that kind of thing
that people can
live to really old ages that's wonderful
right
little babies how many of them die or
children not that many because we have
good healthcare systems right something
to be thankful for in our
where we live and also when we live as
well when
this is obviously not the case
everywhere right in some developing
countries the skew might be more
symmetrical or it might even be
tragically positive depending on you
know what time in history you were
looking at but does that make sense you
can see why this is this is important
once you say negatively skewed i can
understand i can quantify uh what this
country is like based on its mortality